hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his key lecture what is metaphysics
Martin Heidegger is going to begin by
addressing that very question and he'll
talk about it at the beginning of the
lecture and then he'll come back to it
is a key thematic towards the end of the
lecture as well we want to put these
together in order to understand what he
is talking about as the nature and scope
the range of metaphysical inquiry or
interrogation however we want to put the
activity of engaging in metaphysics that
he sees as absolutely central for human
being and something essential to to us
as the kind of being that we are among
the whole field of beings in relation to
being now that's a lot of being language
and we'll come back to that in a moment
at the beginning he he starts by saying
the question what is metaphysics awakens
expectations of a discussion about
metaphysics and then he says I'm going
to pass that up I'm not going to try to
generalize at the very beginning about
the entire field of metaphysics we'll
see why in just a moment he says instead
we're going to take up a particular
metaphysical question that question in
the rest of this this address is going
to be the question of the nothing but
it's also going to be tied in with what
he calls the question of the being of
beings so how are these two connected
that's something that lies within the
realm of metaphysics as we're going to
see now the reason why he says we'll
begin with a particular metaphysical
question is that he says by doing this
we will let ourselves be transposed
directly into metaphysics instead of
hearing some generalizations about well
metaphysics is this and it's the science
of this or the discipline that does this
within philosophy he's going to have us
doing it he's going to have us engaging
in it and then looking at what we are
what we are engaging with in that
so he says only in this way now notice
how he phrases this will we provide
metaphysics the proper occasion to
introduce itself you could say that
what's going on here is something akin
to personification in literary devices
right metaphysics itself has to be
allowed to encounter us to explain
itself to us to to speak to us and you
might go that's a little strange you
know do you mean like a book talks to us
no he means the the activity itself has
to be allowed to show itself to to us
and so he says we're going to begin with
the unfolding of metaphysical inquiry
then try to elaborate the question and
conclude by answering it this is not the
only way to do metaphysics for Heidegger
but this is a fruitful way and he tells
us two key things very early on in the
essay two things that we have to reflect
on a bit
two things that have to do with the very
nature of any genuinely metaphysical
inquiry according to Heidegger so he
calls us the twofold character of
metaphysical interrogation that is when
we are not interrogation like a police
interrogation but when when when we are
talking back and forth and trying to
answer and ask questions about the
beings that were were engaged with so he
tells us the first thing is every
metaphysical question encompasses the
entire range of metaphysical problems so
what does this mean this means that
every single metaphysical question or
problem is going to be interrelated with
all of the others that is it's not going
to be possible to come to any sort of
full resolution or even an understanding
an adequate understanding of them if
they're treated in complete isolation
from each other if they're or if they're
not actually even acknowledged or
addressed so you know to take a few
examples the question of the none
thing that he is going to explore here
is intricately connected with the
problem of the being of beings it's also
connected with the you know range of
logic and the intellect it's also
connected to the question of well do
emotions mean anything metaphysical it's
connected with the issue of human
freedom all of these are going to be
interconnected and what this implies is
that we could approach any given
metaphysical question and then start
untangling it and find a whole bunch of
connections to other metaphysical
questions and problems what this means
is that the field of metaphysics as such
constitutes a comprehensive whole of
which we don't want to separate off or
isolate out all of the parts from each
other because if we do so we risk not
getting to the bottom of a genuinely
metaphysical question it gets even more
complicated with what he's calling the
second part of this twofold character
here's where human beings themselves as
the Enquirer's are going to become
intimately involved he says every
metaphysical question can be asked only
in such a way that the questioner as
such is present with the question and he
goes on to clarify this by saying that
is is placed in question so what does
all of that mean this means that you can
never have objectivity about
metaphysical issues if by objectivity
what you mean is totally stripping away
all of these human beings who are
involved in these metaphysical questions
there are quite a few metaphysical
questions where although we can treat
them in a rather abstract way we're
really talking about human beings to
begin with you know what is history you
know what are emotions you know animals
also come into that you know how does
reason function well the only real
examples of reason that we have to work
with are humans and we can go on and on
and
on and on you know what is a community a
community of what human beings right so
you know there's all sorts of ways in
which metaphysical questions might bear
upon human beings Heidegger is going
further than that he is telling us that
every metaphysical question he has to be
asked in a certain way or perhaps a
range of ways it has to be asked in such
a way that the questioner is present in
the question to the question with the
question that you don't simply remove
yourself you don't try to think about
you know human being as such you know
stripped of all attributes properties
historical location contingency what
Heidegger would call finitude and that
the person who is asking the question is
also placed in question this is very
important so if we're thinking about you
know say the question of freedom and
whether freedom exists and what the
meaning of human freedom is we're not
only asking that in the abstract for
human beings in general we're asking
that for ourselves we are directly
engaged in the question we may in fact
have to engage in some action or some
experiment or some some experimentation
right in order to really dig into the
question we may also have to rely on
what previous human beings who were you
know very thoughtful about these matters
previous metaphysicians for example he
had to say about these things
appropriate their insights and then go
further than than they do so this is a
really important set of distinctions
here that Heidegger is is making he's
telling us that if you want to do
metaphysics in a serious fundamental way
this is this is what is going to be
required for that and then he goes on
they said that from this we must can we
conclude that every metaphysical inquiry
must be posed as a whole and from the
essential position of the
existence that questions and he tells us
we are questioning here and now for
ourselves he'll explain a little bit
later what that means I want to jump
ahead however to where he tells us more
about the nature of metaphysics so he
says that if we look at the original
meaning of metaphysics meta tahu Sica
which is the title of Aristotle's books
that coming after the physics
he says metaphysics derives from this
and the peculiar title is later
interpreted as characterizing the
inquiry the meta or in lanten trans
extending out over beings as such so
Heidegger tells us from this metaphysics
is inquiry beyond or over beings which
aims to recover them as such and as a
whole for our grasp metaphysics is
attempting to take in the totality the
all which includes us the you might say
metaphysic subject the subject who is
engaging in metaphysics and he is going
to go on further from this and draw a
really important corollary but before
that think just for a moment about the
implication of this Heidegger is is
telling us that metaphysics is not
simply about having a representation of
what is or something along those lines
he says it aims to recover beings as
such and as a whole for our grasp it is
a you might say recuperative process it
isn't something to place us where we
belong that is a side of metaphysics
that will often get left out but really
was part of classical metaphysics so he
says in the question concerning the
nothing such an inquiry beyond or over
beings being as a whole takes place it
proves thereby to be a metaphysical
question and then he reiterates these
these two conditions for metaphysical
inquiry and he goes on and he says that
here we go human existence can relate to
beings only if it holds itself out into
the nothing and we're going to talk
about that in other videos what that
means going beyond beings occurs in the
essence of design design is us human
beings and then he says this going
beyond is metaphysics itself he makes a
contrast here he tells us it is not a
division of academic philosophy nor a
field of arbitrary notions metaphysics
belongs to the nature of human being
metaphysics we might say is essential to
human being if we're adopting a rather
Aristotelian way of looking at it where
nature and essence are quite quite
connected another thing that he says is
metaphysics is the basic basic
occurrence of design that is of human
being it is design itself because the
truth of metaphysics dwells in this
groundless ground it stands in closest
proximity to the constantly lurking
possibility of deepest error he says and
he's going to follow up on this by
saying that philosophy cannot be reduced
to science neither can metaphysics be
reduced to science as we understand
science in the present but think about
the implications of this
so if metaphysics is indeed something
that is of the very nature of human
beings we are the creature that engages
in metaphysics or the being that engages
in metaphysics metaphysics is an attempt
to understand being with a capital B to
recuperate the beings to let them speak
to us to re-engage with them all of that
Heidegger says is of the essence or of
the nature of what it means to be a
human being so you know if you think
about different ways in which human
beings have been characterized through
the ages in philosophy we typically talk
about you know man is a rational animal
or sometimes add to it the pregnant
extra qualifier man is a mortal rational
animal Heidegger would be saying
something along the lines of
yes yes that's nice rational great
mortal right sure but man or human being
is the being that engages in metaphysics
this doesn't mean that every single
human being does so in any sort of
explicit way in many cases we may simply
inherit a metaphysical position handed
down to us take it from our culture take
it for granted but it is of our
possibility to realize that nature that
is something that can be opened up for
any of us and that is what Heidegger is
attempting to do in this very essay what
is metaphysics
you